il y a urgence la pandémie n'était rien
à côté du dérèglement climatique on ne
peut même pas imaginer ce qui va arriver
les enfants et les personnes âgées
mourront en premier
nous souffrirons aussi de famines de
pénurie d'eau et de conflits armés
ça ne va faire qu'empirer avec le temps
qu'attendons-nous
pourquoi Monet pourquoi monnaie d'abord
il y a une vitrine on ferait pas ça s'il
y a pas de vitrine pourquoi monnaie
parce que monnaie c'est le pain qui a
sublimé la nature et en faisant ça on
montre qu'on détruit monnaie comme en ce
moment certains détruisent le monde et
l'emmène à sa place c'est un symbole
c'est magnifique je les adore toutes les
deux
crois pas du sujet en fait faisons eu
raison pas eu raison mais on parle pas
de
en fait ça donne envie de s'en de
l'écologie
les gouvernements suédois ils vont voir
ça veut dire oh là là tiens je vais
mettre en place plein de choses parce
que il y a deux meufs qui ont mis du
rouge sur une part une peinture sachant
qu'en plus elle fonctionne et que la
Suède c'est un des pays les plus écolo
en Europe bien sûr aucun sens
le problème c'est qu'en fait tu es
bloqué dans tes sortes de d'obsession
comme ça écolo mais en fait c'est
contre-productif ça sert à rien
en fait c'est de la com parce qu'en plus
tu dis toi-même il y a il y a une sorte
de vitrine donc ça veut dire que c'est
une vitrine c'est juste de la pomme on
est d'accord c'est pour faire une image
c'est pour faire une image choc en plus
parce qu'on l'a vu
là c'est sur le dos elles vont te
défoncer tu vois en plus et tu dis en
plus Gilles c'est très bien ça fait ça
fait réagir mais en fait ça fait un an
qui tartine tous les tableaux de partout
il y a rien qu'elles ailleurs
en Russie quels aient aux Etats-Unis là
où ça pollue vraiment mais pour le coup
en Europe on est plutôt assez répandable
le gouvernement chevrologan ne fait rien
le respect quoi ces engagements dont on
le fait en France le gouvernement
français ne respecte pas ses engagements
c'est le pays numéro 1
renseigne-toi sur la Suède
connaissez pas ce film prenez pas
ce film dans le Maître de Guerre avec
Clint Eastwood bien sûr qu'il arrive il
y a un mec il s'appelle suédois et donc
ils veulent que suédois il défonce qu'il
me dit il y a tous les gars dans le
campus
ça va chier les bulles carrés avec vous
les mecs et là il y a tous les gars ils
se laissent pas ils disent levez-vous
personne se lève ils sont sur le lit ils
font comme ça et les fonds suédois
suédois et là il y a une masse comme ça
un mec un Suédois qui sort comme ça et
la Clint eastwoody du coup
il le défonce et là tous les mecs vous
voyez que j'aime le cinéma
c'est le maître de guerre c'est
incroyable quel film quel film que fait
la
chaise
eux ils sont grands pollueurs nous on
n'est pas on est là mais nous on fait
plein de trucs en fait quoi
de détruire des œufs ça va changer quoi
mais non faites quoi et nous on fait
quoi
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas mais non mais je comprends pas
comment il peut encourager ce genre de
chose c'est quand même un scandale
d'aller toucher au patrimoine on l'a
bien vu avec l'arc de triomphe on le
voit maintenant avec des peintures vous
trouvez ça bien vous encourager des gens
à faire ce genre de choses
[Rires]
vous pouvez défendre ça vous êtes
complètement tarés comment vous pouvez
défendre ce genre d'action mais on ne
fait rien nous on ne fait
n'importe quoi toi tu arrêtes pas de
gueuler depuis des années tu as fait
avancer le monde en quoi mais moi j'agis
mais tu as juges
à part acheter des fringues à Fatou et
faire la vaisselle tu fais quoi
je ne tire pas la chasse d'eau par
exemple voilà j'agis concrètement pour
la voilà et ben regardez voilà c'est
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous faites quoi faire Nico plutôt
que de rire bêtement vous faites quoi
vous la tirez la chasse d'eau Nicolas
[Applaudissements]
ah vas-y le prix du toilettes bah prends
ça dans ta le prix des toilettes sèches
et alors il fait ce qu'il veut il a
gagné son argent honnêtement on a
compris
un trou avec une espèce de trucs
bien fait pour ta gueule